speaking of like couples what's it like
to work with Gwen and Blake they're so
adorable I asked them what is you know
what's the key you guys have been
together you guys are so hot because
they're so happy and in love like really
it's real no it's so real like you know
like they're like they're like making
out they're not making out but they're
like they're they're cuddly with each
other and I'm obsessed with each other I
miss making we're switching okay
um I do I miss making out oh making out
is the best I know I need a hot girl
summer you do need a hot girl summer I'm
ready and ink and anyway what they say
about their their key to like being so
happy is that they're best friends and
they make each other laugh all like
they're laughing all the time that's
like something that's really important
for me how about you it's laughter it's
the most important emotionally stable
and funny
yes yes those are my two favorite things
hard to figure out on a dating app if
they're either yeah totally I was on a
dating app for like 24 hours then I left
why did it make you run away
um because the first kind of DMV was
like aspiring singer songwriter from
Nashville and I was just like I feel
weird because somebody could be using me
does that make sense like you don't know
their intention yeah you don't know
their intentions but even that I'm like
I don't even know when you are just
trying to make friends you're gonna meet
guys that are vetted by your friends
which is amazing I mean should we try
this yeah because you're on the X Factor
how do you approach the voice like what
type of empathy or wisdom what is your
philosophy having actually lived that
life this is absolutely incredible it
really was wow I know we rule we did it
this is really good we killed it we
killed it thank you New York Times for
this amazing recipe thank you New York
Times how do you come you have your full
team now you have team name Camilla like
done in the back you know who your team
is I think that my biggest asset or like
the biggest Advantage I have is that I
started on X Factor on a single
competition show because so much of you
know so much of life is psychological
like it's like
two people could have the exact same
amount of talent is one person is if one
person is being choked up by self-doubt
and anxiety
and the other person is having fun and
enjoying themselves they're gonna give
two completely different performances
you know they're gonna it's gonna be
like two different people
um so I really focus on making sure that
on the psychological part like really
like
making sure that they're reframing
things so that they're having fun
because as I guess like as basic or
simple as that sounds when you're having
fun everybody else is having fun with
you you know and if you're like choked
up then people can't people can't see
you're like choked up from all of the
all of the magic well my gosh I mean as
a coach I want you as a life coach a
voice coach a friend coach a dating
coach I want you as all of those things
too
right exactly
Camila Cabello watch her coach on The
Voice airing Mondays and Tuesdays at 8pm
on NBC and after the break we've got a
little surprise for everyone in this
room don't go anywhere
[Music]